identity gives you a pair of glasses to
see the world through you experience the
world a certain way because of the
multiplicity of your identities and the
certain identities you have what it
brings in science is if someone shows up
has a pair of glasses at seal blue and
then someone shows up and has a pair of
glasses that see yellow suddenly we can
see green
today on Chalk radio moving toward a
more diverse and Equitable field of
science through Hands-On online
education
I'm Sarah Hansen for this episode I
talked with two founders of an online
MIT program that's seeking to make
material science and engineering
education accessible to students Beyond
MIT
the program is called micro or the
materials Initiative for comprehensive
research opportunity
my guests were two of the program's
creators Jessica sandland and Cecile
chezo
my name is Jessica sandland I am a
lecturer in the department of Materials
Science and Engineering I'm Cecile I
used to be a graduate student at MIT I
now graduated in May so I am a MIT PhD
um shipping off to Chicago where I'll be
starting as a faculty in Material
Science and Engineering at Northwestern
University
Jessica and Cecile met while Cecile was
the graduate student representative for
the diversity equity and inclusion
collaborative in the mechanical
engineering Lab at MIT
diversity equity and inclusion or Dei is
at the core of micro's Mission to make
Material Science more welcoming and
accessible to minoritized undergraduate
students
but before we delve into the program's
Mission let's first get clear on a
pretty important term
what is Material Science
Material Science is the study of
materials basically understanding the
materials from the atomic scale all the
way to the macro scale for instance if I
have metal if I process metal a certain
way like I cast it I can make certain
types of objects like a pot for instance
if you want a beautiful Le closet cast
iron skillet kind of thing now if I
shape it as a sheet I can make cans for
Coca-Cola or different other sodas or
that kind of stuff so that's the whole
point of Material Science is really
understanding the link between how do
you make materials from the atomic scale
as a way to a centimeter tons kilogram
scales
for large volume application and how is
it affected at every step of the way
it plays a role in so many different
fields and it's so many different
applications we have people in our
department who are doing work in energy
science they're looking at
sustainability questions they're trying
to figure out new ways of developing
materials for novel medical devices and
I think it just has such a reach for me
that's maybe one of the most exciting
things about Material Science is just
how many different fields it really
touches
Material Science is a fairly new field
that brings together different science
specialties
it didn't used to be its own discipline
until like about the 50s 60s where
people started talking about Material
Science we're relatively young stem
field that initiated from physics
chemistry
engineering altogether
okay so Material Science is this
relatively new field that incorporates
all these different traditional stem
Fields into the study of the materials
we use every day
so what is the materials Initiative for
comprehensive research opportunity
micro it's an online undergraduate
research and learning program that is
for students from minoritized background
and that is focused on Material Science
and Engineering
the initial motivation for this is as I
said earlier Material Science is a
relatively young field
we have a lot of diversity problems that
a lot of stem Fields have but we have
this added difficulty that it's actually
not a topic in high school or in fact in
the majority of undergraduate
institutions you can't major in Material
Science and Engineering the goal of this
program was really to promote our field
of Material Science and Engineering
through a Hands-On
research experience but it needed to be
accessible I know it sounds a little
paradoxical to talk about hands-on
experience in an online program but this
is the whole concept we were pursuing is
like we've seen during the pandemic that
people can do research remotely and can
do very impactful research remotely
I was curious to know more about how
students do this Hands-On research
remotely so Cecile gave me an example
she told me about a participant in the
micro program named Toby Toby is a
mechanical engineering undergrad at the
University of Maryland in Baltimore
County he paired up with an MIT grad
student named Richard
Richard is Material Science student is
looking at making batteries with very
very high capacity based on
nanomaterials
and he's doing that in the lab he's
making different batteries and trying to
figure out how to make them
manufacturable and in high capacity and
what Toby does is he models use a finite
element softwares that is called console
it does it on his laptop remote in into
a server we have in our lab
to simulate what would be the final
properties of a battery depending on the
shape we give the size we give the
material we give for it and how does
that relate to how Richard can change
this process and make the battery even
better by taking information from that
model that Toby is developing and
understanding how different aspects
materials in the battery size Etc can
affect the final properties
one of the core motivations for the
micro program is to create opportunities
for students who have historically been
excluded from pursuing Material Science
and Engineering as a career
it was this idea of taking Material
Science research involve undergraduate
students who may not have a Material
Science Program in their department and
who are part of minoritized communities
so they can learn about Material Science
through the online courses we give them
we don't look for research experience we
look for research potential even if an
undergrad has never done research before
and that's important because in numerous
undergraduates institutions you can't do
research
if they have interest in research and
they explain to us why they're so
interested in research even without
prior research experience they should
apply this is important for us the point
is to reach people who may not have that
opportunity otherwise
part of what makes micro so special is
its emphasis on demonstrating the power
of diversity equity and inclusion in
stem both Cecile and Jessica spoke about
what it was like for them as women
becoming Professionals in the field of
Material Science it left them with an
understanding of the value and
importance of identity which informs
their work at micro
the way I usually describe it is
identity regardless of it if it is a
visible Identity or invisible identity
what it gives you is it gives you a pair
of glasses to see the world through
you experience the world a certain way
because of the multiplicity of your
identities and in the certain identities
you have
what it brings in science is if someone
shows up has a pair of glasses that see
all blue and then someone shows up and
has a pair of glasses that see yellow
suddenly we can see green this is the
power of diversity and Innovation and
really understanding this and there is
example historically of that to take the
example of women in science for instance
the increase of female representative in
the medical field in the United States
in the 80s and 90s
shed new light on understanding disease
and pathologies that affect women such
as breast cancer or different heart
diseases and there was this brand new
wave of innovation that came because you
had more diversity in your Workforce
I came to MIT as an undergraduate for
the first time in 1995. at the time as a
woman in engineering
it looked very different here
but it was also very rapidly changing I
understand yeah from a personal level
what it means as an engineer
to see these role models to see these
people who are doing
the best Material Science and
Engineering work that is being done in
the world and they look a little bit
more like me than they used to back in
1995.
having experienced that Evolution I
think I really appreciate the power of
it in a very real way
when we take the stern of understanding
sustainability and understanding all
those challenges our world is facing
right now diversity of identity brings
diversity of perspective
an ergo faster more meaningful progress
on the scientific level but also on the
human and societal level
[Music]
while getting underrepresented students
through the door here's an important
step supporting these students to then
succeed in their work is another
critical component of the micro program
one of the ways they achieve this is by
providing Hands-On mentorship
Cecile and program co-founder Max
latewell were grad students when the
program was first enacted
Cecile and Max as graduate students I
think were also really really essential
to the success of this program in a way
that I almost could not overstate there
will be talk about sometimes as near
peer mentors they are these very
experienced graduate students who have
been successfully working in this field
for a number of years but they're not so
far away from these undergraduates and
their undergraduate experience they were
able to provide advice they were able to
help with Fellowship applications and
graduate school applications and how do
I write an abstract for this conference
that I want to go to I think that the
barrier for approaching Cecile or
approaching Max for help was much lower
than it is coming to maybe a faculty
member and saying I need help with this
problem I think that having that near
peer mentorship opportunity was
absolutely critical and Max and Cecile
were just so engaged and so fundamental
to the success of that program beyond
the actual micro staff each one of these
students had at least one and ideally
really two research mentors
also
our program had additional components
apart from the research and the material
science curriculum there was a soft
skill component where we organized
Workshop
for the students to learn how to write
an abstract for instance how to define
research questions also skills that are
Beyond technical skill but are super
important if you're thinking about a
research career or even an academic like
additional degrees in academics
the other component was the mentoring
component which is really
teaching
those research mentors on how to provide
meaningful and inclusive mentoring for
these students
the inclusive mentoring training
included a series of worksheets for
mentors that instructed them in things
like effective and inclusive
Communication in a remote environment
planning and managing and more we'll
provide links to these worksheets in the
show notes for this episode
while micro certainly does benefit its
student participants one of my favorite
parts of the conversation was the
importance that Jessica and Cecile put
on how much the mentors and Labs
actually benefited from the work these
highly talented students produced
one of the things that I would really
like to point out is that these students
are engaging in real impactful research
they are doing science they are doing
engineering we talked a lot earlier
about the mentors and what the mentors
have to offer the mentees but I really
think it's also important to point out
that these Laboratories are getting the
work of these talented
really enthusiastic students and they're
bringing new ideas into their lab groups
and they're taking initiative to try new
things I think it's something that we
hope is valuable to our micro students
but it's also a really valuable thing
for the lab groups as well
my favorite example of this is
Nick is a math major I don't think he
had done research before Nick is from
Grand Valley State University
and you apply it as a math major in
micro
and he started doing research on a data
analysis of some chemical
characterization of protein
Nick was like the way you're doing this
there's a better way of doing it with
math
[Music]
you know like I don't understand why you
guys are doing this this way there's a
much better way of doing it there's this
math method that's just gonna work just
fine and he just came up with this
algorithm that just goes through
enormous volume of data to classify
efficiency of markers on protein or
something something that I personally do
not fully understand
what is so funny is then we talked to
his grad student mentor and the
professor of the lab group he was part
of and they were like oh yeah Nick is
great Nick just came up with this thing
that we don't fully understand the math
but it's fantastic it works out great
Ergo yet another example of this like
you come up with another pair of glasses
and you look at this problem and you're
like I have a solution for this that is
so much simpler than what you've been
doing for years
one of the things we at ocw love about
micro is how it harnesses the power of
online learning to make Science
Education more accessible and Equitable
both Jessica and Cecile share this
passion the reason I'm so interested in
and passionate about online learning is
that it has so much potential to
increase access and it has so much
potential to share what we do here at
MIT more broadly I have been working in
online learning at MIT now for like nine
years almost a decade we do a lot of
experiments and we have to do a lot of
experiments because some things that
sound like a good idea really aren't and
some things some things that you don't
think are going to work out can work out
really really really well and if you
don't try them you don't learn this was
just one of those projects but I thought
this could work really well and it does
two things that I'm really really
excited about this is a tangible
opportunity to increase diversity in our
field and this is a tangible way of
exposing more people to Material Science
and Engineering to me if I can use my
online learning experience to do those
things I want to do that because that's
why I work in this field
[Music]
each student that participated in micro
has written a brief description of their
work within their MIT Labs if you're
interested in seeing what research the
participants did and learning more about
what's possible in a remote setting you
can check them out at
micro.mit.edu you can also learn about
how to become a participant in the
program there as well
you'll also find all of the micro
Creative Commons licensed teaching
materials on our website at
ocw.mit.edu you can help others find
these resources and this podcast by
leaving us a rating and review until
next time signing off from Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm your host Sarah Hansen
from MIT opencourseware
MIT chalk radios producers include
myself Brett patchy and Dave leshansky
show notes for this episode were written
by Peter Chipman the micro supplemental
resource was built on opencourseware by
Shiba nemat Nasser we're funded by MIT
open learning and supporters like you
open courseware will always be free and
open for you to learn anytime anywhere
millions of people learn with ocw
resources each month and none of it
would be possible without the generosity
of ocw users who give back when they can
we hope you'll consider making a
donation to help power free and open
resources from MIT for Learners like you